i i've never met a criminal say i have
maybe once
that says come arrest me officer i'm
doing all kind of crimes here
let me write down the crimes that i'm
committing so i go to prison for life
nobody's gonna do there's actually the
famous story of that guy who robbed a
bank
for one dollar and then after that he
went and sat down and waited to get
arrested because he had cancer
oh he wanted to get health care from
prison because he couldn't otherwise oh
yeah yeah
that's a crazy stuff i had a guy i had a
guy we were a midnight shift man i'm
just
hanging out just finished crazy writing
crazy case reports and we're at the qt
getting ready to get some donuts this
guy
come up to us screaming arrest me
take me to jail help arrest me and we
like duke stop
what is your problem he pulls out a bag
of weed because we said we said no we're
not arresting you we're not
he pulls out a bag of weeds like arrest
me now and we all looked at each other
like
who's going to write this case so some
people do it
they do it why do you do it but but eric
he was high on drugs
yeah and he was he was schizophrenic so
he was afraid people were trying to kill
him
so he wanted to go to jail to be safe
and he happened to have weed in his
pocket
and he presented it and that's what we
need to go to a doctor man
i know we we took him we took him we
took him to jail
for for a few reasons i think he ended
up having a warrant he wasn't possession
of marijuana but he can't get help from
jail
they they will refer you to medical
services if you have that problems in
jail in in
tucson you ever see the movie watchmen i
don't think so
i love that movie it was a it was a much
better comic graphic novel
but uh uh in the movie it's basically
about a bunch of superheroes vigilantes
they wear masks
uh that's like they wear masks yeah it's
like part of the premise is that
they're not necessarily all super
powered there's people who put on
costumes and then fight
you know crime and uh a law passes where
you can't wear masks anymore like mass
vigilantism is a crime
and so there's a scene in the movie i
think it's in the comic as well uh
where these two heroes are reminiscing
about this one villain who was
constantly like arrest me
arrest me and they were like we'd always
ignore him and then rorschach who's like
this he's one of the characters he's a
moral absolutist
and they're like whatever happened to
the guy and then night owl goes
rorschach dropped him dropped him down
an elevator shaft
yeah but that's what it reminds me of
the guy walking walking up to you being
like arrest me here's drugs take me in
yeah in in the case of uh eric garner
like
this is this is the thing that that i
think is a two-fold
thing here eric garner shouldn't have
been breaking the law
he had been arrested 40-some times
before this one some of his arrests
included selling lucy some of them
included resistant arrests
but you got to think about capitalism
and freedoms
the store that's selling full price
cigarettes
is getting gypped because you got this
guy
who refused to work for the store or get
a real job is selling cigarettes for a
cheaper price right in front
right in front of his business and the
star called the cops stork i don't know
if they call the cops in this instance
but
somebody called the cops because they
showed up not unless they were
surveilling him
right right which these guys look like
they were in plain clothes but i don't
know if they are
pd i don't know if that's the way they
do pd in in out there or not
the the problem i have is you know when
i see this video of the eric garner
situation
and i'm like it pisses me off i see the
george floyd thing it pisses me off
i see a lot of these videos that
everybody gets pissed off
and in my initial reaction when these
stories started you know becoming
prominent through social media
was sympathy and support for the
activists then i started
actually looking at the evidence then
the george floyd thing was basically a
big punch in the gut for me
because when the george floyd thing
happened conservatives liberals
moderates everybody was pissed off
everybody i i think i was pretty upset
yep everybody was coming out saying nah
this is this is not good we want justice
and here's what pissed me off then the
evidence comes in then you're like oh
geez dude
we we all jumped the gun a little bit
but here's the problem
when people who are like moderate
liberal conservative of any
persuasion actually investigate and find
out oh man we
we might have been wrong on this one
they come out and say it
when they think there's injustice they
call for justice
but these leftists when they're wrong
they just stop talking about it they
should ignore it just disappears
yeah and they have to you know for me i
always maintain that i thought that what
he did was dumb and i you know that guy
caused
a hailstorm that didn't need to happen
because george floyd could have died but
he could have
he could have played to the camera you
know you're a white man on a black man
and he's saying i can't breathe he
crying for his mama even if he's wrong
even if he's lying even he's playing
you play to the camera dude because the
optics are just horrible here
and the dude is subdued and if you need
to jump on his neck again you can
but to just sit there with your hands in
the pockets and he goes unconscious and
you still don't do anything right
but i never said he would be found
guilty in the court of law and
i think i think the reason why is
because i know policing you know and i
reserve my opinions on
on the court of law because all the
evidence is hasn't been presented and
these things keep occurring like brianna
taylor is another one
you know they keep saying that these
people are are
unjustifiably killed by police creating
an environment of
of of hatred towards police which is a
big lie it's it's all a farce
there are some people who were killed by
police and they in
they didn't deserve to be killed by
police you know i think walter scott was
um philando i think philando castile was
the only iffy one for me what happened
with him
he got shot he was reaching he was
reaching for his identification
presumably and again he had a gun
in his pocket so to the officer it looks
like he's reaching for the gun
it was a legal gun and he was in his
game no no no no no no let's talk about
that
it wasn't legal because he was smoking
pot no not
at the time because the toxicology
results that came back in the court of
law
in his trial deemed that he was
intoxicated meaning that he had ingested
marijuana at the time he got his permit
and therefore he illegally obtained a
concealed carry pyramid
and even while he was illegally in
possession of a concealed care permit he
was violating the law at the time of his
death because he was carrying a gun and
he had
uh illegal drugs in his possession he
was in possession of illegal
illegal drugs while carrying a firearm
so he was all kind of messed up
and but does that mean he need to die no
it doesn't but what what it
speaks to is the the questionable
nature of what is the cop seeing and
what is he doing
and he's reaching he said for his id but
the cop sees a gun coming out of his
pocket
he should have had it in a holster he
should be responsible gun owner
and and it probably wouldn't have been
that iffy this is where i get more
little libertarian and all the stuff i
don't blame
an individual cop for the most part i
understand individuals bear
responsibility for the actions they take
for the orders they follow but if we're
asking cops to effectively
you know be neutral arbiters of the law
not saying they always are
or typically are but that's the idea
it's like okay we've all voted
legislators came in passed this law now
we got to have people to enforce the law
so we have cops do it
that cop's not playing favorites you
know first of all he doesn't want to get
jammed up and have his time wasted by
someone doing something dumb
and you're going to argue and claim oh i
should be allowed to do this i should be
allowed to do this
look man i know the laws you know the
law is i'm i'm i'm doing what was asked
of me by the community
the problem i see as i see though is the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
it doesn't say anything about whether or
not you smoke pot or whatever and i also
think the war on drugs is wrong
i do think there's there's a fair
assessment about you know wielding a gun
under the influence for sure so that's
where
you know things get iffy with with lando
uh
but i'm looking at it like we got cops
uh the floyd the floyd circumstance
specifically
floyd was freaking out because i think
the cops caught a mid-drug deal
you know maurice lester hall was it was
testified by floyd's girlfriend she was
that he was the he was their dealer
they find the speed ball they see the
blood in his system i think what
happened was
it was a 20 counterfeit bill not a big
deal but when the cops showed up
floyd was like we're you know he's it's
like right now it's going down this is
serious charges yeah so he freaks out
if it wasn't illegal to do drugs like
that
and you had a right i don't think he
would have freaked out i think
he was driving you can't do that while
you're right that's true this is true
this is this is the point that some that
some people make and
it sounds good in theory but in
application it doesn't work
if you know if you are you see how crazy
he was
you see him in the store you saw him he
was jumping and struggling to stand up
at some point how was he operating a
motor vehicle
but then you you also see that because
of his drug habit he's now using the
counterfeit
money to purchase things yeah so he's in
a sense he's in a sense of desperation
so if the counterfeit money doesn't work
what is he going to do next to get his
high
what is he going to do next to get what
he wants he's going to start stealing
things he's going to start robbing
people
he's going to start breaking he's going
to start breaking other laws that affect
other people
if you were smoking crack in your own
house nobody cares
i've never i've never caught somebody
smoking crack in their own house i never
never because i don't ever randomly
break into this house there he is
there you go kicked oh he got crack
everywhere you know what happens if i
just kick his door in and get out of
here
is pressed in court he'll never go to
jail for the fruit of the poison tree
yeah so
you know exclusionary rules i have
already started down the path of of uh
doing illegal stuff none of this is
gonna count
so it doesn't happen so but but what i
do see is that
the reason why philando castile and
these laws are in place that a person is
a possession of a firearm with illegal
substances
it's because of the drug game it's
because of drug dealing
it's because people are violent all of
these young people that are getting
killed in the inner city are getting
killed in this ring
of drugs gangs gun violence
all of these things which are trying to
which police are trying to combat
via the legislators and so
it's not a big deal to me because i
don't carry illegal
drugs on me while i'm carrying my
firearm i just don't do it
if i want to smoke weed i smoke at the
house and if i want to smoke it illegal
just look at it at the house
yeah legal in most places now it's
leaking in most places arizona just
passed a law
that is living in arizona i don't know
if it's in effect yet but they passed
the law which i think is
counterproductive but at the end of the
day
i don't care police don't care they
don't care
like about people doing drugs about
people smoking weed oh yeah like it's
not it's not a big deal i i i got these
stories from the south side where it's
like
you know my 16 year old friends would be
like hanging out skating at a park or
whatever they're smoking pot and they'd
see like a cop pull up and then i'll
freak out like throw it the cops would
laugh and
there was one story where apparently
like my like my friends were to park
they're smoking
they see a cop roll up they freak out
throw the pipe the cops laugh and go yo
we don't care we're looking for a guy
who's like 5 10
he's wearing a brown shirt you see him
like not he's like later kids and they
just peel they just drive off and
they're like
yeah i mean the freak out that people
have is probably the most dangerous
because floyd may have been able to beat
the case in the court of law
for the if he didn't freak out and be
weird he
it would have just been a counterfeit
thing and the store could choose not to
prosecute
now i don't know if that's the way that
they do it there but in the state of
arizona
the store has to prosecute your crime
against them doesn't matter
well it's a state that that brings
charges not not in not in
so so there's a you know there's a time
period in which
crimes can be prosecuted and not right
so if i go to a convenience store and i
steal candy at a convenience store and
it's just shoplifting i committed a
crime
a store can say i don't want to
prosecute therefore the police
department will not arrest me
because the story didn't want to
prosecute however they can prosecute
as long as it's within a year or so of
that crime or whatever whatever
the limitation statute of limitations is
for that particular crime so
even only thing that changes in the
state of arizona and it's probably
universal across the board is domestic
violence
so a woman getting her butt kicked can't
say no i don't want to prosecute my baby
daddy today
i know the state picks up those charges
she has no choice yeah
other crimes against persons that are
not involved in domestic violence people
can decide not to prosecute well
my understanding of that is that what's
actually happening is the prosecutor
the prosecutor say without a witness we
wouldn't win
so it's it's it's always the state
versus you know the people
ultimately it's the state but we make
those determinations at
the police level so we will if there's
no complaint
right what are you charging the person
with exactly exactly so but they make
that
but technically they make the decision
we still we still report it we still
followed up and a detective can still
follow up with the case and they can
change their mind
but at the at the moment most people
they don't want to prosecute because
george floyd is a crackhead i mean he's
a he's a drug user
meth user he probably smoked crack too
i'm sure no but he uses drugs
and so when a cop showed up
maybe he would have come in and
reconciled it and the cops could have
assisted him in doing that but he
panicked because he got his dope dealer
who had a bag of drugs probably
and he panicked and swallowed dope and i
know people
personally who sell drugs who have done
things like that and that's
that's a common occurrence they swallow
dope because if you swallow it
now you don't have it in your possession
and you can't be charged with it they
call it hooven
that's what he said that's what i've
learned in the last few days and uh he
said it blatantly to the officer i was
who well so
yeah but the way pbs reports that is it
meant
basketball yeah right i was playing
basketball yeah i mean that's probably
why it's coded
i'm sure he's not playing basketball as
high as he was
oh he's lying yeah oh he's lying but but
in your experiences hooping
typically referred to swallowing i never
heard i've never heard of the term
yeah i mean neither nobody ever used
that term i mean it's probably cultural
you said hooping for basketball hooping
for drugs for drugs either
i've never heard hooping for drugs after
hooping for basketball exactly i've
heard shooting hoops i've never heard i
was hooping
i mean i never heard a person admit that
they swallowed right right they admitted
that they swallowed drugs unless they
wanted medical attention
and they would say hey man like hey i
need the man ambulance i swallowed i
swallowed
i think he did want the ambulance he did
but the thing is i think he went about
it in a roundabout way because he was so
high
he was trying to convey to them that i
want medical attention because i don't
want to go to jail
but he didn't want to go ahead and admit
that i swallowed the dope that
homeboy just sold me right here in front
of the store thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you